mark how are you I am awesome happy
Thanksgiving day you too what are you
thankful for oh well I am thankful for
my mom and dad and I'll tell you why
there four years ago
quick story four years ago basically
drowning in debt working a minimum-wage
job paying the minimum payments which is
like 60 bucks it was like a $32,000 loan
debt and just out of the blue my mom
called me in it's because my grandmother
passed away that year too and so they
basically said hey mark we uh we want
you to move forward in life and we want
to we want to pay off his debt for you
so you can start actually living living
your life and Wow they just paid it all
off Wow how much I barely just started
weeping not bad I'm bad now that's such
your free man
very good I was crazy how can we help
today yeah so I'm looking to pay $12,000
car and I've never bought a car
dealership before it's really only been
through friends helping me out giving me
like their old car for a great price and
so I'm going to pay all in cash yeah as
you say debt is dumb mm-hmm the my
questions are we get a better deal at a
dealership if you tell them up front
you're going to pay for a paid all in
cash and all their different strategies
to getting them to go low as possible
and then maybe even lower than that
and what are your recommendations for
getting best price for a car well the
best way to negotiate on anything is to
have a lot of knowledge about the
situation as well as the value of things
and so if you're going to look at a
particular car you need to do some
internet research on what that car is
worth hitting Kelling Blue Book and
finding out what the wholesale value is
which is likely with that dealership
paid for that car on and in you know
doing some research on the car itself
see if there's any articles out there
about repairs or you know how reliable
it is or those kinds of things or
insurance rates on that type of car is
that an expensive car to insure versus
another car in the same price range
those kinds of things and then you go in
there armed you may very well know more
about
that particular car than the salesman
will because that salesman is trying to
keep up with a whole bunch of cars that
are coming and going all the time and
you know I've even laid the Kelly Blue
Book printout on the desk at the
dealership and go you know that's
wholesale that's what you paid for it
probably right around there if you pay
much more than that you paid too much as
a dealer and you know this is the
trading or this is the private sale
which would be what an individual would
sell so apparently we're going to land
somewhere between there well I'm going
to buy it down next to wholesale I'm
going to expect them to make a profit so
dealers very seldom do you steal a car
from a dealer because they have a
certain number of dollars tied up in
that car and they've always got to get
those dollars out at least or lose money
and they have the ability to sell the
car at Manheim or one of the other
dealer auctions they can just load these
you know they load up ten cars put them
on a truck send them to the auction and
they'll pretty much all bring wholesale
so they can turn that car into money at
wholesale just about any time they want
to so they have no reason to sell it in
most cases well below wholesale now
sometimes there's an exception to that
and sometimes wholesale is moving you
remember a few years ago oh my goodness
it's been many years ago now I guess
gasoline got up over $5 a gallon yeah I
was who dick here yeah I was looking for
a four-wheel drive Chevy pickup with a
big engine in it at that time and I
didn't worry it wasn't worried about the
gas mileage and I just wanted a big
truck and says a perfect time to go
shopping for that truck because the
bottom fell out of the prices on them
and in that case that dealer may have
paid you know twelve thousand dollars
for that four-wheel-drive used Chevy
truck but because gas prices made them
very unpopular it might he might only be
able to get ten thousand for it on the
open market on a wholesale right so what
I had done is some research as I hate
gas prices are dinging these things up
he's kind of stuck in that truck right
and so in that case I may have bought
that truck below what he had in it but
most of the time they're going to want
to at least break even because they can
take that car and
sell it at an auction so just to do some
research he with the most knowledge
usually wins a negotiation and yeah I
would tell them I'm paying cash this is
not a finance deal if we come to terms I
will leave here with the truck and
without my money if we don't come to
terms I'm going to leave here with my
money and I'm going to keep shopping so
yeah that's a pretty strong negotiating
thing because other let's pretend you
were a dealer selling a car a guy who
has to go get a loan or get approved for
a loan may or may not be able to get the
loan and may or may not be able to do
the deal but when you're standing there
with $12,000 cash you are what's known
as a buyer I mean there's there's a
transaction going to occur if we can
agree on a price and that's the thing
you want to get into there and what you
can inform them hey this particular
vehicle is very expensive to insure
because the insurance rates are higher
on this $12,000 car than this other
$12,000 car I like this car and I'm
willing to take that on but that's going
to cause you guys to have trouble
selling this car and you can just talk
it through with them but it's not it's
not running down the vehicle or anything
and then of course you've got to
accurately appraise the value of it
based on its mileage based on its
condition and those kinds of things when
you're comparing it to the internet
pricing and if you've done all of that
you know generally you're in a pretty
good place to make a reasonable deal now
if you can find the car from an
individual that's in good shape the
individual paid a whole lot more than
what you're going to pay for that car
four years ago when it's gone down in
value so they don't have like cost of
goods sold in it they didn't buy it
three weeks ago for $10,000 now they're
trying to sell it for 12 that you know
they bought it five years ago for
$22,000 and now it's worth 10 and and so
that what they paid for it is not
relevant in the discussion and sometimes
they are more motivated they need to get
out of that car and you're standing
there with the cash that's where you can
buy stuff sometimes below wholesale is
from an individual because they've not
got the actual hard costs tied up in it
now the car may not have been checked
out as well you need to may need to take
it and have it checked out all those
kinds of things you need to check
quality and all that
but the difference is is they didn't buy
three weeks ago for X number of dollars
that they have to at least get that or
to lose money and car dealers aren't the
business of losing money and they
shouldn't be
I'm not running them down I endorsed
several good used car dealers in several
markets and proud to do it hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]